[Music]
step into a world where the future of
healthcare isn't just a distant dream
but a reality waiting for you I'm Serena
young assistant professor of biomedical
data science and an instructor for an
Innovative health and AI oncampus
program happening in April
2024 transforming Healthcare through big
data analytics and AI is your
opportunity to break barriers and
reshape the landscape of healthcare get
ready to strategically integrate
technology into your practice lead with
disruptive insights and Foster
Innovation that goes beyond the ordinary
with lectures Hands-On experiences real
world applications and networking
opportunities you'll embark on a journey
to becoming a leader driving
organizational success in healthcare
secure your spot today and join us from
April 8th to 11th 202 24 be at the
Forefront of healthcare's innovation
Evolution we hope you'll join us on the
Stanford
[Music]
campus